newly released data shows that our
portrait of america is changing and
changing dramatically the total number
of white people has fallen for the first
time ever recorded we're talking all the
way back to 1790. just over 61 percent
of the american population is white down
from 75 percent just 20 years ago the
2020 census also found that more than 85
percent of us now live in or near a
major city a less rural country edelke
joins us now from washington ed good
morning to you there are dozens and
dozens of stories and things you could
talk about in this census report but
you're going to take a look at it from
the nation's capital perspective how is
it going to change things there
well good morning tony demographers have
been predicting it for years but the new
numbers show that this country is
diversifying far faster than expected
with democrats in tight control of
congress just by the narrowest of
margins and the midterms right around
the corner this will have huge
implications for american politics
americans filled out their forms and the
results are in the nation's white
population slid by 8.6 percent in the
last decade while the number of latino
and asian americans ballooned by more
than 20 and 30 percent and the number of
african americans increased by more than
5 percent the change is perhaps most
apparent among the nation's youth nearly
half of americans under 18 are now
non-white the future of this nation
really is latino arturo vargas is with
the nonpartisan national association of
latino elected officials latinos
accounted for over half
of the u.s population increase over the
past decade
we need to make sure
that the new electoral districts are
going to be drawn reflect
these population changes and
specifically the increase of the latino
population which we saw
actually happening in america's largest
cities many advocates also hope that as
states start redrawing boundaries they
curb the practice of gerrymandering or
drawing twisted congressional districts
to benefit one party over the other
there's a great example of this here in
maryland right there they vote in the
fourth congressional district but across
the street they vote in the fifth
congressional district
driving just three miles from that
divided neighborhood you can cross
through three democratic congressional
districts the politician chooses their
district and their voters they can and
if they don't like a group of their
voters they carve them off and move them
someplace else
they can create their own
safe district what we call safe seats at
the end of our drive we met michael goff
maryland president of common cause which
pushes states to turn census numbers
over to independent commissions to draw
nonpartisan congressional maps it's a
once in a 10-year process it's probably
the most important political
development of the next 10 years is
happening the next few months and most
voters don't even know about it
as we said all of this comes ahead of
the 2022 midterms and the fight over the
balance of power in dozens of state
legislatures and congress for example
republicans now control more of the
states that are set to pick up
congressional seats so they could
potentially gerrymander democrats out of
districts to make gains of course dana
democrats could do the same to
republicans in the states they control
we'll be monitoring this over the next
year yeah interesting the idea that
maybe somebody independent would take a
look at that as well ed thank you very
much